if we can pay to treat wastewater why
not waste carbon
[Music]
roughly half of my monthly water bills
pay for piping water to my london flat
the other half is for treating the
wastewater i produce
that most unremarkable effects has a
climate lesson
we already paid to manage some of the
waste we generate daily
makers of electronics batteries and
vehicles are mandated by governments to
clean up after the product reaches its
end why don't we have laws for managing
carbon dioxide discharge
a group of researchers at oxford
university say that we should
they call it the carbon take back
obligation
the idea is simple companies that
extract fossil fuels should ensure that
all the carbon dioxide generated from
burning the fuels is put back into the
ground
technology to do this already exists
it's called carbon capture and storage
the problem is that it's expensive
because fuel charge for dumping carbon
dioxide in the air
bringing in a carbon take-back
obligation will change that and help
make the technology cheaper the
researchers suggest starting small with
only about 10 percent of the carbon
extracted put back underground by 2030.
then ramping up to 100 by 2050 when the
world needs to reach net zero
this might sound like a carbon tax which
it is
except instead of charging the polluter
to pay for polluting the polluter is
charged for cleaning up
the costs are also quite reasonable if
you consider a story from the 19th
century
the summer of 1858 brought unusually hot
and dry weather which caused london's
broken sewer system to stop functioning
altogether the period came to be known
as the great stink and citizens were
aghast over the next decade the
government spent about two percent of
its annual economic output to build a
modern sewer system
and as my water bills attest london
londoners continue to spend substantial
sums to maintain a utility we take for
granted
until people think throwing co2 in the
air is like throwing poop on the street
we won't spend what we need to to tackle
climate change
this is net zero i am akshay tarati for
more like this follow us on your
favorite platforms